MUCH HAS HAPPENED SINCE OUR LAST
PUBLIC HEARING ON JULY 21st.
AS THE CHAIRMAN MENTIONED WE
RECEIVED NEW AND VOLUMINOUS
DOCUMENTATION FROM THE SECRET
SERVICE WHICH WE CONTINUE TO
ANALYZE.
WE'VE RECEIVED NEW WITNESS
TESTIMONY INCLUDING ABOUT
EFFORTS TO OBSTRUCT OUR
INVESTIGATION AND CONCEAL KEY
FACTS.
AND ACCORDING TO PUBLIC
REPORTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN
PURSUING MANY OF THE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED IN OUR PRIOR
HEARINGS.
OUR COMMITTEE MAY ULTIMATELY
DECIDE TO MAKE A SERIES OF
CRIMINAL REFERRALS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR ROLE IS NOT
TO MAKE DECISIONS REGARDING
PROSECUTION.
THE PREAMBLE TO OUR CONSTITUTION
RECITES AMONG ITS PURPOSES TO,
QUOTE, ESTABLISH JUSTICE AND OUR
NATION'S JUDICIARY AND U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
A KEY ELEMENT OF THIS
COMMITTEE'S RESPONSIBILITY IS TO
PROPOSE REFORMS TO PREVENT
JANUARY 6th FROM EVER HAPPENING
AGAIN.
WE'VE ALREADY PROPOSED AND THE
HOUSE HAS NOW PASSED A BILL TO
AMEND THE ELECTORAL COUNTERACT
TO HELP ENSURE THAT NO OTHER
FUTURE PLOTS TO OVERTURN AN
ELECTION CAN SUCCEED.
AND WE WILL MAKE FURTHER
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS IN OUR
FINAL REPORT BASED IN PART ON
THE EVIDENCE YOU WILL HEAR
TODAY.
OUR HEARINGS LAST SUMMER BEGAN
WITH AN OUTLINE OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S MULTIPART PLAN TO
OVERTURN THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
WE THEN PROCEEDED TO DEMONSTRATE
EACH OF THESE ELEMENTS IN DETAIL
WITH MORE THAN 20 HOURS OF
EVIDENCE.
TODAY WE WILL SEE NEW EVIDENCE
BUT AS THE CHAIRMAN SAID WE WILL
ALSO SYMPTOM THIEZ EVIDENCE
YOU'VE SEEN BEFORE.
THE VAST WEIGHT OF EVIDENCE
PRESENTED SO FAR HAS SHOWN US
THAT THE CENTRAL CAUSE OF
JANUARY 6th WAS ONE MAN, DONALD
TRUMP, WHO MANY OTHERS FOLLOWED.
NONE OF THIS WOULD HAVE HAPPENED
WITHOUT HIM.
HE WAS PERSONALLY AND
SUBSTANTIALLY INVOLVED IN ALL OF
IT.
EXACTLY HOW DID ONE MAN CAUSE
ALL OF THIS?
TODAY WE WILL FOCUS ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S STATE OF MIND, HIS
INTENT, HIS MOTIVATIONS AND HOW
HE SPURRED OTHERS TO DO HIS
BIDDING.
AND HOW ANOTHER JANUARY 6th
COULD HAPPEN AGAIN IF WE DO NOT
TAKE NECESSARY ACTION TO PREVENT
IT.
AS YOU VIEW OUR EVIDENCE TODAY,
I WOULD SUGGEST A FOCUS ON THE
FOLLOWING POINTS, FIRST, AS YOU
WILL SEE, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD A
PREMEDITATED PLAN TO DECLARE
THAT THE ELECTION WAS FRAUDULENT
AND STOLEN BEFORE ELECTION DAY,
BEFORE HE KNEW THE ELECTION
RESULTS.
HE MADE HIS STOLEN ELECTION
CLAIMS ON ELECTION NIGHT AGAINST
THE ADVICE OF HIS CAMPAIGN
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE IN HAND.
THEN OVER THE NEXT TWO MONTHS HE
SOUGHT TO FIND THOSE WHO WOULD
HELP HIM INVENT AND SPREAD LIES
ABOUT THE WIDESPREAD FRAUD.
MANY OF THOSE WHO STEPPED
FORWARD TO HELP INCLUDING RUDY
GIULIANI KNEW THEY NEVER HAD
REAL EVIDENCE SUFFICIENT TO
CHANGE THE ELECTION RESULTS AND
ON THE EVENING OF JANUARY 5th
THEY ADMITTED THEY WERE STILL
TRYING TO FIND THAT PHANTOM
EVIDENCE.
OF COURSE, AS A RESULT OF MAKING
INTENTIONALLY FALSE CLAIMS OF
ELECTION FRAUD, MR. GIULIANI'S
LICENSE TO PRACTICE LAW HAS NOW
BEEN SUSPENDED.
SECOND, PLEASE RECOGNIZE THAT
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP WAS IN A
UNIQUE POSITION, BETTER INFORMED
ABOUT THE ABSENCE OF WIDESPREAD
ELECTION FRAUD THAN ALMOST ANY
OTHER AMERICAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S OWN CAMPAIGN
EXPERTS TOLD HIM THAT THERE WAS
NO EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT HIS
CLAIMS.
HIS OWN JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
APPOINTEES INVESTIGATED THE
ELECTION FRAUD CLAIMS AND TOLD
HIM POINT BLANK THEY WERE FALSE.
IN MID-DECEMBER 2020, PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S SENIOR ADVISERS TOLD HIM
THE TIME HAD COME TO CONCEDE THE
ELECTION.
DONALD TRUMP KNEW THE COURTS HAD
RULED AGAINST HIM.
HE HAD ALL OF THIS INFORMATION
BUT STILL HE MADE THE CONSCIOUS
CHOICE TO CLAIM FRAUDULENTLY
THAT THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
TO PRESSURE STATE OFFICIALS TO
CHANGE ELECTION RESULTS, TO
MANUFACTURE FAKE ELECTORAL
SLATES, TO ATTEMPT TO CORRUPT
OUR DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, TO
SUMMON TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
SUPPORTERS TO WASHINGTON KNOWING
THAT THEY WERE ANGRY, KNOWING
THAT SOME OF THEM WERE ARMED, HE
SENT THEM TO THE CAPITOL.
THEN AS THE RIOT WAS UNDERWAY,
HE INCITED HIS SUPPORTERS TO
FURTHER VIOLENCE BY PUBLICLY
CONDEMNING HIS VICE PRESIDENT.
AND THEN HE REFUSED FOR HOURS TO
DISBAND HIS RIOTING SUPPORTERS
AND INSTRUCT THEM TO LEAVE EVEN
WHEN HE WAS BEGGED REPEATEDLY TO
DO SO.
NONE OF THIS IS NORMAL OR
ACCEPTABLE OR LAWFUL IN OUR
REPUBLIC.
THIRD, PLEASE CONSIDER TODAY WHO
HAD A HAND IN DEFEATING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, BILL BARR,
JEFF ROSEN AND OTHERS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, STATE
REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS, WHITE
HOUSE STAFF WHO BLOCKED
PROPOSALS TO MOBILIZE THE
MILITARY TO SEIZE VOTING
MACHINES AND RUN NEW ELECTIONS,
OUR CAPITOL POLICE, AIDED BY THE
METROPOLITAN POLICE, OTHER
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUR
NATIONAL GUARD WHO ARRIVED LATER
IN THE AFTERNOON, ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE HAD A HAND IN STOPPING
DONALD TRUMP.
THIS LEADS US TO A KEY QUESTION,
WHY WOULD AMERICANS ASSUME THAT
OUR CONSTITUTION AND OUR
INSTITUTIONS IN OUR REPUBLIC ARE
INVULNERABLE TO ANOTHER ATTACK?
WHY WOULD WE ASSUME THAT THOSE
INSTITUTIONS WILL NOT FALTER
NEXT TIME?
A KEY LESSON OF THIS
INVESTIGATION IS THIS, OUR
INSTITUTIONS ONLY HOLD WHEN MEN
AND WOMEN OF GOOD FAITH MAKE
THEM HOLD REGARDLESS OF THE
POLITICAL COST.
WE HAVE NO GUARANTEE THAT THESE
MEN AND WOMEN WILL BE IN PLACE
NEXT TIME.
ANY FUTURE PRESIDENT INCLINED TO
ATTEMPT WHAT DONALD TRUMP DID IN
2020 HAS NOW LEARNED NOT TO
INSTALL PEOPLE WHO COULD STAND
IN THE WAY.
AND ALSO PLEASE CONSIDER THIS,
THE RULINGS OF OUR COURTS ARE
RESPECTED AND OBEYED BECAUSE WE
AS CITIZENS PLEDGE TO ACCEPT AND
HONOR THEM.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, OUR PRESIDENT
WHO HAS A CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION TO FAITHFULLY EXECUTE
THE LAWS SWEARS TO ACCEPT THEM.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE PRESIDENT
DISREGARDS THE COURT'S RULINGS
AS ILLEGITIMATE, WHEN HE
DISREGARDS THE RULE OF LAW?
THAT, MY FELLOW CITIZENS, BREAKS
OUR REPUBLIC.
FINALLY AS YOU VIEW THE EVIDENCE
TODAY, ALSO CONSIDER THIS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP KNEW FROM
UNASSAILABLE SOURCES THAT HIS
ELECTION FRAUD CLAIMS WERE
FALSE.
HE ADMITTED HE HAD LOST THE
ELECTION.
HE TOOK ACTIONS CONSISTENT WITH
THAT BELIEF.
CLAIMS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACTUALLY THOUGHT THE ELECTION
WAS STOLEN ARE NOT SUPPORTED BY
FACT AND ARE NOT A DEFENSE.
THERE IS NO DEFENSE THAT DONALD
TRUMP WAS DUPED OR IRRATIONAL.
NO PRESIDENT CAN DEFY THE RULE
OF LAW AND ACT THIS WAY IN A
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC, PERIOD.
MR. CHAIRMAN, OUR NATION'S
FEDERAL JUDGES ARE SWORN TO DO
IMPARTIAL JUSTICE, TO PRESERVE
OUR CONSTITUTION AND PRESERVE
OUR UNION, DOZENS OF THESE
JUDGES HAVE BEEN ADDRESSING
JANUARY 6th CASES AND MANY HAVE
GIVEN US PLAIN, UNMISTAKABLE
WARNINGS ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF
OUR REPUBLIC.
LET ME READ FROM ONE JUDGE'S
STATEMENT GIVEN AT A RECENT
SENTENCING HEARING.
QUOTE, HIGH RANKING MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND STATE OFFICIALS WHO
KNOW PERFECTLY WELL THE CLAIM OF
FRAUD WAS AND IS UNTRUE AND THAT
THE ELECTION WAS LEGITIMATE ARE
SO AFRAID OF LOSING THEIR POWER
THEY WON'T SAY SO.
IT HAS TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR, THAT
IT IS NOT PATRIOTISM, IT IS NOT
STANDING UP FOR AMERICA TO STAND
UP FOR ONE MAN WHO KNOWS FULL
WELL THAT HE LOST INSTEAD OF THE
CONSTITUTION HE WAS TRYING TO
SUBVERT.
MR. CHAIRMAN, THE VIOLENCE AND
LAWLESSNESS OF JANUARY 6th WAS
UNJUSTIFIABLE BUT OUR NATION
CANNOT ONLY PUNISH THE FOOT
SOLDIERS WHO STORMED OUR
CAPITOL.
THOSE WHO PLANNED TO OVERTURN
OUR ELECTION AND BROUGHT US TO
THE POINT OF VIOLENCE MUST ALSO
BE ACCOUNTABLE.
WITH EVERY EFFORT TO EXCUSE OR
JUSTIFY THE CONDUCT OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, WE CHIP AWAY
AT THE FOUNDATION OF OUR
REPUBLIC.
INDEFENSIBLE CONDUCT IS
DEFENDED, INEXCUSABLE CONDUCT IS
EXCUSED.
WITHOUT ACCOUNTABILITY, IT ALL
BECOMES NORMAL AND IT WILL
RECUR.
SO AS WE WATCH THE EVIDENCE
TODAY, PLEASE CONSIDER WHERE OUR
NATION IS IN ITS HISTORY.
CONSIDER WHETHER WE CAN SURVIVE
FOR ANOTHER 246 YEARS.
MOST PEOPLE IN MOST PLACES ON
EARTH HAVE NOT BEEN FREE.
AMERICA IS AN EXCEPTION AND
AMERICA CONTINUES ONLY BECAUSE
WE BIND OURSELVES TO OUR
FOUNDERS' PRINCIPLES, TO OUR
CONSTITUTION.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT SOME
PRINCIPLES MUST BE BEYOND
POLITICS, INVIOLATE AND MORE
IMPORTANT THAN ANY SINGLE
AMERICAN WHO HAS EVER LIVED.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
I YIELD BACK.